bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
au sommaire de ça vous regarde ce soir
le coronavirus fait son entrée à
l'assemblée le député
les républicains du haut-rhin jean-luc
reitzer a été contaminé tout comme un
salarié de la buvette parlementaire et
quatre autres membres du personnel qui
sont en cours de dépistage comment le
palais bourbon à gérer cette situation
coup de chance l'hémicycle évident pour
cause de trêve électorale et pour autant
beaucoup de questions se posent
on en parle ce soir dans notre grand
débat ou parlera aussi de ses plumes du
pouvoir avec le journaliste michaël
moreau dans son dernier livre ils nous
racontent les histoires secrètes des
grands discours présidentiel celle de
ces hommes de l'ombre qui ont planché
des nuits entières à l'elysée pour
satisfaire les exigences de leur patron
et trouver les mots justes et puis avec
lui ce soir sylvain fort
l'ancienne plume d'emmanuel macron à
l'elysée tombe le masque sur ce plateau
n'est plus notre grand témoin ce soir
est une grande voix de la radio dans le
pays un visage dès le cp son émission
rembobine à est un succès le journaliste
patrick cohen est avec nous ce soir
voilà donc pour le programme c'est parti
acheter vert n'oubliez pas on y va
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
nos invités en plateau ce soir patrick
cohen bonsoir bonsoir et merci d'être
notre grand témoin on va passer une
heure ensemble pour commenter
l'actualité ou à parler de rembobinage
c'est un carton sur lcp et c'est un
succès critique on en verra quelques
extraits on parlera aussi des plumes
présidentielle avec je le disais nickel
moreau et sylvain fort mais on commence
avec le coronavirus qui a donc gagné
l'assemblée nationale bonsoir bruno
fuchs machine elle vous êtes député
modem du haut rhin département largement
un touché par le corona virus ou des
mesures exceptionnelles ont été
annoncées par le préfet aujourd'hui 84
contamination dont votre collègue les
républicains jean luc reitzer
hospitalisé à mulhouse mulhouse vous
nous direz si vous avez des nouvelles de
lui astrid mort de mon soir et bienvenue
à vous représenter les collaborateurs
parlementaires secrétaire général
adjoint de l'unsa us cp vous nous direz
au fond quelle consigne vous avez reçu
si les assistants parlementaires
continuent à travailler ici dans
l'enceinte du palais bourbon est l'âme
d'un gars va bienvenus on serait vous
des journalistes lcp et vous avez évoqué
avec nous tous les scénarios possibles à
l'assemblée nationale enfin alex taylor
chroniqueur dans cette émission on va
parler du coronavirus dans la presse je
vous donne la parole dans un instant
mais on commence comme tous les soirs
avec celui qui nous plante le décor avec
son ton et son regard
c'est stéphane si j'ai bien compris
stéphane blakowski tout de suite
[Musique]
[Rires]
il a osé me l'enlève m c'est pour le
moment qui s'est bien compris ces
soirées bien compris me fait quand même
un métier dangereux myriam bas on le
savait en choisissant ce métier que ça
peut être dangereux quand on court sous
les balles dans un pays en guerre ça
peut être dangereux oui quand on fait
des enquêtes sur la mafia oui ça aussi
ça peut être dangereux
bon est ce que se sont dit comme ça il
n'ya rien ne nous met pas du tout rien à
voir avec le journalisme
nous on est journaliste à lci qu' un
endroit hyper sécurisé c'est vrai quand
on rentre à l'assemblée c'est pire que
dans un aéroport une fois pendant 5 il
ya des gendarmes dans tous les coins
avec des gros fusil noir et même nous là
en ce moment donc on est dans le studio
lcp donc au sous-sol de l'assemblée à la
profondeur dans une cure atomique
normalement il ne peut rien nous arriver
c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup
de mesures de sécurité à l'assemblée
sauf qu'elles sont elles sont totalement
inutiles pour protéger l'assemblée du
corps un navire villa ce qui contredit
on redevient sérieux puisque a eu deux
cas à l'assemblée donc un je crois un
employé la buvette qui l'état de santé
n'inspire pas d'inquiétude et puis
surtout jean luc reitzer qui lui était
un peu plus âgés qui matin est en
réanimation à mulhouse donc on a
évidemment une pensée on souhaite
vivement qu'il puisse reprendre sa place
à l'assemblée c'est le siège de 75 dans
l'écriture donc qu'il reprenne sa place
avec d autres et puis on a évidemment
une pensée pour sa famille on se demande
surtout si ce virus va va bloquer le
fonctionnement du palais bourbon
dans l'immédiat n'a pas de grosses
conséquences parce qu'ils trouvent que
avec les élections municipales
les députés n'ont pas siégé pendant les
deux semaines à venir donc ça réduit un
peu mécaniquement le nombre de
collaborateurs d'autres personnels de
l'assemblée ma faim il reste comme
quelques centaines de personnes
rassemblées dont les équipes de lcp se
retrouve d'une certaine façon car de
l'actualité bah là on est au coeur
on a parlé de ça un peu de loin on l'a
vu venir de chine italie ça se rapproche
mais ces cinq six émissions avec
toujours la même consigne myriam surtout
ne pas céder à la psychose à en dix ans
à sable ça me rappelle pas thomas
porcher qui est venu hier soir donc dans
cette émission un économiste et lui il
était très stressée dès d'emblée sur le
virus déjà au maquillage
il y avait une chaîne info qui disait
150 cas supplémentaires il est devenu
blême il a fallu soutenir son sentent
bon l'été autour de lui en coûter combat
soyez raisonnable ne vais quand même pas
céder à la psychose
bah oui on l'a moyennement rassurer
même sur le plateau c'est pas du tout ça
qui me fait sourire c'est qu'en fait on
a parlé du corps aux navires juste avant
et qu'elle a tous et c'est tout avant de
parler de votre alors thomas on est
désolé parce que quand il vivait d'hier
que vous ne risquez absolument rien à
l'assemblée on était sincère parce que à
ce moment là effectivement la menace
n'apparaissait pas clairement nous
j'espère que tout va bien seulement
garder c'est vrai qu'il va falloir
prendre peut-être encore plus de
précautions
ah bah oui venant aux précautions
justement je voulais vous en parler
parce que effectivement on explique à
chaque fois que à nos téléspectateurs
qui a des consignes très simples pour
éviter la contamination
je le rappelle pas de poignées de mains
pas de bise c'est marqué dans tous les
journaux pas de poignée d'humains pas de
bise bon alors comment ça se passe en
coulisses à bien regarder comment ça se
passe en coulisses dans ça vous regarde
on a donc là c'est une fille gal
directrice de la rédaction de bfm des
personnes les mieux informés de france
qui vous claque la bise allègrement
derrière mime le pauvre nicolas baverez
cas rien demandé qui se passait rien
enfin comment on peut donner comme ça
des consignes de jean ne pas le
respecter soi-même voulait un autre
exemple à faire regarder le professeur
saldmann le spécialiste de la lutte
contre les infections qu'est ce qui fait
qu'ils jettent sur vous une accolade
vervins j'aurais dû être un peu plus
près d'angers montpetit gel et drôle a
comme voilà évidemment je vous souhaite
que ses contacts un petit peu trop
étroit n'ait pas de conséquences
et puis voilà six au total toutefois il
y avait une suspension carrément de
l'activité je tiens à vous faire valoir
le bon côté des choses regarder si on
est en vacances voilà on va peut-être
partir un peu plus loin parce que
évidemment les prix sont cassés ils sont
cassés en ce moment dans les transports
aériens
merci stéphane sens voilà sans
transition et blague à part bruno fuchs
est ce que vous avez des nouvelles de ce
député du haut rhin de votre marque la
dernière heure bien sûr mais je sais
qu'ils en situation très difficile il
combat le virus depuis hier avec
beaucoup de force j'imagine mais la
situation est sérieuse donc dans toute
l'alsace et le aurait en particulier il
ya un grand mouvement de sympathie et de
solidarité pour le donner
toutes les ondes positives pour qu'il
puisse arriver à surmonter cette épreuve
et bien sûr comme vous l'avez dit on a
une pensée très très forte était très
émue pour pour sa famille aussi
vous êtes surpris au fond le virus voilà
est en phase de circuler alors pas
exactement phase 3 mai dans le pays
gagne l'assemblée vous êtes surpris les
députés sont pas épargnés comme les
autres français et non on est au coeur
de la vie des citoyens vous avez des
députés de tous les territoires de
france qui viennent ici tous les
week-ends il sert c'est pas 500 mille
mains il voit des gens il leur parle ils
s'embrassent on le voit c'est quand même
assez voilà ça m'était de proximité
aussi une activité de proximité
le fait qu'il y ait des cas de
contamination à l'assemblée ça vous
inquiète environ sort d'un grand et si
vous êtes où tous les députés du rpt
quasiment et c'est ça on voyait une
grande proximité et quand on travaille
en commission vous devrez membres encore
plus fortement proche de que sur un
studio télé quand quand vous allez on
parle de la buvette est un lieu dans
lequel on va se restaurer très
rapidement et il ya beaucoup de réunions
qui sont là également c'est un lieu de
rendez-vous on y vient on voit la
buvette se dire aux rendez vous et on
discute de dossiers c'est un peu ça le
le terme générique et bien vous avez une
très grande proximité de cas qui sont
apparus mais il y en a quatre
aujourd'hui personnes qui vont être
testés actuellement on aura les
résultats assez assez rapidement donc
c'est pas étonnant ils sont est étonnant
qu'il n'y ait pas vu la façon dont le
virus circule en france aujourd'hui qu'
on n'est pas à l'assemblée mais
l'assemblée nationale
il ya des consignes qui ont été données
vous avez l'impression que voilà de
bonnes des consignes données
vous l'avez bien les consignes sont pas
toujours respectées mois depuis lundi je
ne serre la main de personne d'ailleurs
je trouve qu'on est un peu proche dans d
autres vous n'allez contre des personnes
mais si s'expliquer aussi c'est que le
fait que la santé soit fermée depuis
hier soir n'a aucun rapport avec le fait
qu'il y ait des cas voilà avérés au sein
du palais beaumont quelques pas d'un
coup de chance
cet appel un mail électorale
indépendante dû siéger aujourd'hui
demain et dimanche également sur le
projet de loi organique des retraites et
il a été débattu plus rapidement que
prévu donc on a terminé hier soir mais
on aurait pu siéger encore aujourd'hui
effectivement il ya une trêve de deux
semaines qui tombe à pic mais la
question est de savoir maintenant
comment les les parlementaires vont se
comporter sur le terrain de l'altération
et si le siège à nouveau avec mm
après les après la trêve électorale on a
quand même croise et quelques-uns de vos
collègues dans les couloirs du
palais-bourbon hélène bonduelle et
eloïse grégoire leur demandait s'il
allait bien
il s'agit de ne pas céder à une panique
particulière dès lors où les consignes
qui ont été données à la fois par les
autorités de santé
les consignes qui sont données par la
présidence de l'assemblée nationale sont
sont respectés il n'y a pas de deux
problématiques particulières l'assemblée
nationale reste un lieu ouvert
l'assemblée nationale reste un lieu
aujourd'hui où il y encore des visites
non j'ai accueilli un groupe ce matin de
d'enfants dans le cadre du parlement des
enfants à la précision d'entrée de jeu
les visites de groupe et notamment
d'enfants toutes les visites de groupes
ont été annulés un pour les jours les
jours les semaines à venir au palais
beaumont tête une réaction patrick ça
touche tout le monde forcément le fait
que cette crise à la taille mais aussi
des hommes politiques des élus la
représentation symboliquement est-ce que
ça ça change quelque chose que c'est pas
plus inquiétant pour les français que
dont je pense que ça
que ce à compter du moment où ça ça
touche tout le monde ça donne ça peut
toucher la représentation nationale
moi j'ai été frappées dans les premières
cartes de l'épidémie par le fait que les
grandes villes les métropoles soit
complètement épargné c'était des foyers
qui était localisé en dehors dans des
zones rurales doit évidemment mais les
villes ne connaissait aucun aucune
aucune victime manifestement si je puis
dire et et sans inquiéter davantage le
virus est entré dans paris et a fait ses
premières victimes puisque d'après ce
qu'on sait de les contaminations ont
bien eu lieu dans l'enceinte de
l'assemblée nationale du palais bourbon
et pas dans les circonscriptions
occident on a peut-être que vous avez
des informations
c'est plutôt cette réunion en prison
j'ai ri on peut faire des déductions et
privés de vue se tiendrait était à
l'origine il ya cette fille de l'église
évangélique où il est plus de 2000
personnes réunies pendant une semaine
dans un endroit de gelos extrêmement
fermé et donc il est fort probable
qu'ils aient une grande partie de ses
fidèles qui ont été au moins a explosé
il ya des décadents paris et donc les
cinq premiers cas qu'on a constatée dans
le haut-rhin ce sont des cas dans deux
villages qui sont de la circonscription
de jean luc reitzer donc il est assez
probable en tout cas que ces pannes ces
voyages qui a pu le le le rendre malade
mais plutôt une rencontre avec un de ses
fidèles
on a parlé de ses relations vingtaine de
départements d'une déduction
on va revenir à l'assemblée on sait que
la présidence suisse a quasiment heure
par heure il ya eu déjà plusieurs
consignes plusieurs réunions
expliquez-nous déjà donc le nombre de
cas elsa et quelles sont les mesures
concrètes qui ont été prises deux cas
avérés on en a parlé donc le député du
haut-rhin jean-luc reitzer et puis un
salarié de la buvette de l'assemblée et
puis il ya quatre autres personnels de
l'assemblée bien qu'ils sont en cours de
dépistage dont 4 cas suspects
aujourd'hui la présidence de l'assemblée
a enchaîné les réunions un sèche et
c'est exceptionnel une réunion avec les
collaborateurs parlementaires et puis
justement la rs l'agencé régionale de
santé bien elle est venue pour faire lé
enquête épidémiologique juste
déterminer quelle est la cause de la
contamination la chaîne de contamination
la présidence fait des communiqués
régulier pour informer sur la situation
des enquêtes épidémiologiques comme pour
tous ceux qui sont contaminés et ne joue
pas comme tous les autres sites d note
envoyée à la presse mais aussi aux
députés appelant à une grande vigilance
par exemple pour ceux qui ont fréquenté
la buvette et un des restaurants les 3 4
et 5 mars ce dernier donc on rappelle
des restrictions sur la vie sociale et
vend éviter de fréquenter
c'était le 2 mars une réunion d'équipé 2
mars au dow est bon elle des
restrictions donc de la vie sociale pas
de bise pas de serrage de mains pas de
visite aux aînés par exemple le contrôle
de la température et puis vous l'avait
dit ce matin ça a un peu étonné y avait
encore beaucoup de visites des groupes
de visite à l'assemblée nationale bon ça
c'est interdit maintenant et puis les
collaborateurs vont être amenés à
télétravailler pendant cette trêve de
deux semaines elle et nous dire comment
ils vont faire
est-ce que la séance parlementaire est
ce que l'assemblée peut rouvrir après
les élections c'est le 23 mars à ce que
exact c'est raisonnable ou pas alors
déjà on le rappelle en vous l'avez dit
pendant deux semaines l'assemblée est
fermé à l'est pas en 14 n c'est prévu
c'est la trêve des municipales ça
soulage quand même un petit peu les
personnels de dire que pendant deux
semaines on va pouvoir désinfecter les
lieux pour l'instant pour l'heure il
n'est pas question de reporter la
réouverture de l'assemblée le 23 mars
mais je sais que dans d'autres pays on
peut se poser la question au royaume uni
par exemple il ya une hypothèse est bien
c'est de fermer le parlement on sait que
les députés alors il rencontre est
ministère fermé exactement il rencontre
l'habitude de l'ade rejet le parlement
trouve quelques mois plus habituée la
décision n'est pas prise en compte dans
la décision n'est pas prêt du tout mais
ça que les députés on peut dire que
c'est des supers vecteurs et rencontrent
énormément de monde sur le terrain ils
viennent de partout en france et donc
effectivement ça peut favoriser la
propagation du virus
et puis une dernière information n'a
appelé l'historien de l'assemblée bruno
fuligni pour savoir s'il y avait déjà eu
des précédents dans son souvenir il y en
a pas mais je vous rappelle qu'il ya
déjà un député en 1919 qui est décédé de
la grippe espagnole et puis il ya
casimir perier voilà comme des millions
de français puis casimir périer le
président du conseil lui les décédés du
choléra le choléra il l'avait attrapé
lors d'une visite à l'hôtel dieu
itay les malades à ce moment là il avait
d'ailleurs eu un pressentiment avant de
rentrer il ne voulait plus à rentrer
dans la salle il est décédé à ce moment
là alors je vous parle de choléra de
grippe espagnole c'est pas pour
inquiéter tout le monde c'était bien sûr
y'a longtemps la médecine a depuis fait
énormément de progrès c'est elsa patrick
cohen vous demandez forcément là dans la
grippe espagnole c'est c'était le a
évolué en h1n1 s'est pas c'est pas c'est
pas si loin le le virus existe encore
même s'il a muté et ici les moins
virulents qu'il l'était en 1918-1919
mais voilà et encore une actualité des
virus et des bactéries
on est dans un moment un peu spéciale où
on nous dit qu'on est au fond sur le
seuil du fameux stade iii où le virus
circulera dans tout le pays et est au
fond ce que ce que disent les fondeurs
pouvoirs publics c'est d'écouter les
médecins les scientifiques et d'en faire
appel à la raison ce qui parfois un peu
contre intuitif c'est à dire qu'en fait
on nous dit mesures barrières mais tout
ce qui est mesures drastiques de
fermeture alors qu'on voit quoi en
italie c'est toutes les écoles du pays
qui sont fermés ne serait plus utile
est-ce que vous pensez que les français
seront capables de comprendre ça chez
moi c'est un équilibre à trouver comme
ils sont plus intelligents que les
autres
non c'est un équilibre à trouver moi
j'ai été évidemment frappé comme comme
vous tous sans doute parler les premiers
sondages qui montraient à la fois
l'inquiétude des français et surtout
leur incrédulité face au discours public
et au discours du gouvernement comme des
autorités de santé d'ailleurs puisqu'il
y avait un grand nombre de français qui
disait que le gouvernement leur cacher
des choses c'était un premier sondage
bfm y avait près de la moitié des
français je crois je me souviens plus du
du chiffre exactement dont aura des
conséquences sur les élections
franchement je ne sais pas là aussi il
ya eu un autre sondage qui montrait que
75% des des gens n'avaient pas peur
d'eux d'aller dans un dans un bureau de
vote
honnêtement je grimpe à 1 % de gens qui
n'iraient pas voter ça fait non 75%
c'est au-dessus de la participation
habituelle à une élection dont 75 sont
prêts à aller voter
75 % disent qu'ils n'ont pas peur
d'aller dans un bureau doit donc 6 75% à
y voler on est au dessus des taux de
participation habituelle maintenant pour
les dernières élections il faut prendre
des mesures très précises comme on l'a
fait dans le haut rhin avec un taux de
propagation extrêmement élevé par
rapport au reste de la france mais que
la clé de résolution à long terme parce
que c'est une des pistes mais qui peut
durer 4 5 8 semaines on ne sait pas donc
on va arrêter la france comme ça la clé
c'est quand même que chacun chaque
français se responsabilisent et
justement respectent les mesures de
protection soit pour ne pas véhiculer
inoculé quelqu'un s'il s il est
aujourd'hui porteur soit a soit
l'inversé
c'est ça la clé et son affaire a
commenté un peu plus politique je
voulais vraiment remercier aujourd'hui
vous féliciter la responsabilité de
l'ensemble des partis politiques
on n'est pas une crise qui est politisé
voulait l'ensemble des partis là-dessus
bien ensemble et les séquelles à une
exception près c'est leur asthme en
national je trouve ça absolument honteux
on a 1 1 de l'étranger partout la france
est félicité par sa qualité dans
laquelle pour la par laquelle
aujourd'hui elle fait face à cette crise
c'était encore un papier du courrier
international de la semaine dernière qui
montre à quel point
voilà vous pourrez parler de l'italie
qui est un bon contre exemple de ce
qu'il ne faut pas trop faire est le seul
parti qui ne jouent pas cet élément là
qui cherche à faire de la politique
bas de gamme et et politicienne c'est
leur asthme en national et quand on
prétend être
quand ils réclamaient la fermeture des
frontières c'est ça mais bien sûr de la
grippe espagnole l'effrontée a été
quasiment fermé et me dire ça pas
empêché des centaines de milliers de
personnes de mourir très rapidement donc
c'est pas du tout là la solution si
chacun se responsabilise pas forcément
le virus va passer et donc quand on
prétend être présidente de la république
il faut garder son sang froid
il faut être calme il faut que gérer les
choses calmement avec beaucoup
d'efficacité il faut pas comme ça
prospérer dans un populisme absolument
inféconds voilà bien mais alors avant
d'en venir à cette question des
collaborateurs parce qu'ils sont aussi
nombreux que les députés ont forcément
ça nous intéresse de savoir si vous
continuez à travailler aussi de la même
manière et bien une forme de trêve
électorale
on va aller rejoindre pire vatin c'est
fanny d'ailleurs ce qui l'a interrogée
par skype parce que figurez vous que
c'est un député en quarantaine le
quotidien c'est le télétravail entre
l'ordinateur les mails le smartphone ça
n'empêche pas de sortir il faut surtout
éviter au maximum les contacts
heureusement ça m'empêche pas d'aller à
la boulangerie par exemple mais il faut
être prudent il faut y aller quand y'a
personne et puis mettre un masque
voilà servent atteint en quarantaine
député de l'oise et chacun y raphaël
legendre
bonsoir chroniqueur dans cette émission
est journaliste économique au point
astrid morne alors le présenter pardon à
l'opinion pardonnez moi j'ai peur vous
vous représentez donc les collaborateurs
parlementaires comment ça se passe pour
vous apparemment vous sortait à peine
d'une réunion au palais bourbon avec
avec le cabinet du président tout à fait
avec le cabinet du président et la
questure qui s'occupe de l'aspect
matériel en fait de l'avis de
l'assemblée nationale on vit les choses
avec inquiétude mais on n'a pas encore
de panique
je pense qu'il ya des choses qui ont été
prises des mesures qui ont été prises
très rapidement une information qui
circule aussi très bien depuis le début
de la crise avec des courriers
assez fréquent et puis les syndicats
sans contact est aussi souvent pour bien
comprendre vous continuez à travailler à
l'assemblée vous choisissez le
télétravail ou parce que c'est la trêve
électorale au fond même les
collaborateurs mettent un peu en suspens
alors pendant les trêves parlementaire
on entre à continuer à travailler
habituellement en circonscription à
paris et à paris aussi parce qu'il ya
des choses à préparer des dossiers a
travaillé lors il ya eu une première
indication
ou la présidence avait indiqué que le
travail n'était pas proscrit et
maintenant on en vient à une deuxième
phase on le télétravail est davantage
envisagée avec des aspects pratiques qui
sont mis en place avec par exemple un
rappel automatique sur nos lignes
téléphoniques privées donc ça va être
grandement facilité la question était
plutôt de savoir si l'assemblée allait
pouvoir donné cet ordre là ou s'il
fallait de faire les choses de gré à gré
puisque nous sommes employés
individuellement par chaque il faut
rappeler que c'est des contrats de droit
privé on l'a les français l'ont
découvert à la faveur de de la sphère de
la sphère fillon dernière question vous
avez pu discuter avec les collaborateurs
de ce député du haut-rhin jean-luc
reitzer j'imagine qu'ils soient assez
inquiet j'ai pas pu discuter avec eux
j'ai d'autres collègues qui l'ont en
tout cas des informations oui on est
tous évidemment un petit peu inquiet
sachant qu'on est dans un bouillon de
culture on à 577 députés qui viennent de
577 endroits différents y à peu près
autant de collaborateurs à l'assemblée
en circonscription années 2000 en tout
donc on est en contact permanent et
c'est un peu compliqué parfois oui après
qu elle vous vouliez ajouter un mot sur
les assistants parlementaires et moi je
suis très heureux d'entendre mes
collaborateurs parlementaires ce que
c'est un métier depuis dix jours quand
on discute beaucoup la définition et les
moyens ces éléments au procès de
pénélope fillon alors on ne sait pas
évidemment si elle a fait un travail qui
méritaient salaire mais on a la
certitude au vu de ce qui a été examiné
pendant le procès que pénales fillon
n'avait aucune chance aucun risque
d'attraper elle le corona dans laquelle
elle travaillait donc je me demande si
c'est pas une méthode la méthode
pénélope ne devrait pas être étendu à
l'ensemble des collaborateurs
parlementaires et des collaborateurs qui
travaillent en circonscriptions iraient
qui travaillent à l'assemblée elle
travaillait en cire compte le travail et
surtout de chez elle sans mettre les
pieds
alors avant de clore ce chapitre sur le
gros navires us avec les laboratoires
qui travaillent avec passion quand même
on va on va rappeler ce qu'a dit le
président de la république on n'a pas le
temps de l'écouté mais au delà des
gestes-barrières la mesure
supplémentaire du jour il était en
déplacement dans une maison de retraite
dans un ehpad c'est au fond de protéger
nos aînés cesser sa formule et donc
éviter au maximum le contact avec les
personnes âgées qui sont plus fragiles
alex taylor que nous raconte la presse
européenne
complètement monopolisé par ce thème là
complètement fou l'europe par rapport à
la semaine d'année où c'était un peu
léger comme ans complètement flippé avec
de nouveaux cas d'infection par tous et
les premiers décès dans certains pays
par exemple les pays bas ce matin
premier mort un homme de 86 ans à
rotterdam premier cas au vatican signalé
ce matin le bilan ne cesse d'augmenter
en belgique 50 nouveaux cas détectés 109
ont tous contaminés avec un papier assez
terrible sur un entrepreneur de liège
contaminé cantonné à domicile à la
famille qui fait face à une campagne de
dénigrement
je cite le soir de bruxelles écrit
des pestiférés du moyen âge s'agite sur
les réseaux sociaux
en espagne on s'en prend à l'origine de
la maladie tous ces humains suivez mon
regard qui mange des animaux sauvages
sans contrôle royal cette image
voilà une véritable poudrière pour la
santé humaine
pin pon mix une église espagnol qui
maintient le culte cardyn prêtre il faut
extérioriser l'amour
après tous les chrétiens des temps
anciens devait faire face eux à la lèpre
est à la peine alors au niveau politique
en europe
alors il ya tout je sais pas ce que
cette image mais angela merkel ne
s'attendait pas à ce que son ministre de
l'intérieur en servant prennent à la
lettre les consignes au regard des parcs
on a donc la chancellière à bien la
rigueur allemande façon les allemands
sont très obsédé par définition et des
gangs en ce moment parce que la
vaccination contre la rougeole devient
votée par le parlement obligatoires
cette semaine est ce que vous savez
comment dire obligation de vaccination
en allemande non à 112 est très bon non
non je sais très germanique alors c'est
imply alors ce qui déjà les virus et
boris johnson mon préféré comme vous
savez a fait une conférence de presse
soit disons pour rassurer les gens
apparemment regardez cet extrait les
faits les bras m'en tombent
je serre les mains tout le temps je me
suis rendu à l'hôpital avec des malades
du coronavirus et j'ai serré la main à
tout le monde et je continue à le faire
c'est à chacun de se décider alors là
vous avez entendu avec la buav parce que
c'est beaucoup plus des titans est
farfelu en vo la reine en tout cas
prendre des mesures beaucoup plus
responsable devoir compter la noble idée
jean d'un gang nettement plus longs que
d'habitude
et puis enfin hier est paru dans le
telegraph l'article qu'on attendait tous
fait des télégraphes second pit bull pro
briques site et qui dit que la
propagation du corona virus et la faute
à et oui vous avez compris l'union
voilà et ben voilà c'est fait d alors
j'ai cherché un peu d'humour quand même
ce serait à certaines certains journaux
qui essaie de calmer la panique
les belges ont gardé tout le monde enfin
supermarchés belges regardez vous avez
des offres sur les bières de bière
corona et vous avez gratuite
l'autre bière belge très connu la mort
subite et initiatives souvenir très
sympathique qui se passe en lombardie en
italie le pays de loin le plus touché en
europe
c'est une poète qui a commencé à mettre
des post-it partout donc les gens le
font ne vous inquiétez pas tout ira
mieux bientôt donc je le sais très
sympathique pour rassurer les gens c'est
partout en lombardie ont souvent des
petits post-it les gens se mettent sous
les arbres sur les fenêtres tout ira
bientôt mieux candidat italien save a
terminé avec avec vous rappeler le
journée à meaux qui inquiète on
n'économise pas se casser un peu
l'ambiance y pala en période de crise et
le mot de récession est ce que les
conséquences économiques en fallait
jusque là sur bien sûr c'est la grande
question du moment est ce que l'europe
et la france vont entrer en récession à
cause de la crise du cours d'un virus
alors on va d'abord définir ce qu'est
une récession en économie ces deux
trimestres consécutifs de recul du pib
or il se trouve qu'on a déjà fait la
moitié du chemin puisque au quatrième
trimestre 2010 9
le pipe français a reculé de 0,1 pour
cent donc si l'économie recul au premier
trimestre 2009 1 et bien nous entrerons
officiellement en récession des mois
prochain on attendait 0 3% de croissance
au premier trimestre le seul
fait le seul arrêt de la chine et des
importations de la chine qui ont chuté
de 40% en ce début d'année suffirait
selon certains économistes à faire
basculer la france dans le rouge au
premier trimestre avec un impact de 0,5
pour cent 0.53 on est en récession dès
le mois d'avril
ah oui je sais c'est qu'il y avait
autant d'impact sur des importations
chinois ces séances 0,5 point de deux
filtres et 0,5 point de pib au premier
trimestre effectivement et ça donne
l'ampleur de l'important dans l'est de
la chine la chine mondiaux il fait
confiance
alors donc si on doit ce souci est bien
évidemment de la crise sanitaire est
bien l'une des premières victimes
c'est l'économie on commence à le voir
en france
aujourd'hui vous avez 400 entreprises
qui ont d'ores et déjà fait des demandes
de chômage partiel en l'hôtellerie
certains secteurs sont plus touchés que
d'autres
évidemment tout ce qui touche au
tourisme puisque les touristes
asiatiques ne viennent plus
les touristes français aussi en france
se déplacent de moins en moins c'est
moins 20% d'impact sur le chiffre
d'affaires du secteur de l'hôtellerie
dans les zones les plus touchées
c'est très important l'événementiel
évidemment on a parlé de beaucoup de
suppressions de salons professionnels
hier encore le maire de cannes appelé à
des aides substantielles lui le verre je
devais animer deux conférences et par
les grands salons professionnels mais
vous avez aussi tous les petits salons
les petites réunions etc
c'est 350 mille emplois en france le
secteur des petits séminaires dans
l'aérien on parle là au niveau mondial
d'une paire de plus de 100 milliards de
dollars cette année enfin vous voyez ces
chiffres sont absolument colossaux on
peut rajouter des pertes de 12 milliards
dans le luxe un milliard pour les vins
et spiritueux en france et les
exportations vers la chine
donc on a un choc de demande extrêmement
important et ce qui est très inquiétant
c'est que suite à ce choc de demain
qu'on risque d'avoir ce qu'on appelle un
choc d'offre
c'est à dire qu'on va commencer à avoir
d'ici quinze jours trois semaines d
hôtellerie
les pièces détachées pour faire court
qu'on peut apporter notamment de chine
il ya un petit décalage par rapport au
blocage de la chine parce que il faut
entre 15 jours et un mois pour les porte
containers pour arriver en europe
il délivre en général entre 15 jours et
un mois de stock et donc ça on l'aura au
mois d'avril ce sera la deuxième si je
puis dire donc ce sera effectivement ça
risque d'être quand même merci beaucoup
d'être venu sur ce plateau nous parler à
la fois de cette crise à l'assemblée
dans le pays et en europe vous restez
avec nous pas très content parce qu'on
va parler un petit peu de vous à présent
et notamment de votre actualité et de
rembobinage ce rendez vous désormais
installé sur lcp petit best-of regarder
bonjour à tous bienvenue à rembobine à
l'émission qui s'amusent à jouer dans
les archives de l'ina
bonjour alain duhamel bonjour bonjour
anne sinclair moi j'ai fait un bon jour
donne de connaux jean-patrick bonjour
bertrand delanoë jeu bonjour nicolas
hulot bonjour patrick anna karina à 26
ans vous étiez déjà une actrice très
très demandés de ville vadim rivette et
bien sûr jean luc godard qui vous avait
révélé vous étiez là marianne2 de
pierrot le fou avec belmondo qu'est-ce
que je peux faire c'est pas quoi faire
mais quel casting impressionnant
oui mais les gens ont plaisir à revenir
pour commenter de d'anciennes émissions
ou des choses des événements auxquels
ils ont participé
la dernière interview c'était sûrement
l'une de ses dernières jeu
c'était quelques mois effectivement
avance avant sa disparition elle était
13 ans très en forme et très très
heureux surtout de revoir ans avec new
and à cette comédie musicale mythique
alors on va commenter ces images de
robin à cette émission mais d'abord
j'accueille nos invités bonsoir sylvain
fort et merci infiniment d'avoir accepté
notre invitation votre parole est rare
vous êtes l'ancien conseiller d'emmanuel
maquereau en charge de ces discours son
ancienne plume et des questions de
mémoire vous supervisez aujourd'hui la
collection artistique de françois
pinault et bonsoir michaël moreau vous
êtes l'auteur de ce livre qui vient de
paraître dans toutes les bonnes
librairies vous êtes journaliste les
plumes du pouvoir chez plon dont on va
parler dans quelques minutes d'abord
rembobinage eux le disait patrick cohen
c'est tout simple concept c'est vraiment
voilà revisiter les grandes émissions du
patrimoine télévisuel télévisuelle grâce
à l'ina est ce que vous êtes surpris que
ça marche avec ceux qui les ont fait ces
émissions là et ben écoutez on est on en
est très heureux en tout cas que il ya
autant de déco et et d'accueil l'idéal
et c'est pas de moi un c'est 30 les
guilaine chenu lcp avec avec les équipes
de linas et de proposer non pas des
comme ça s'est beaucoup fait ces
dernières années n'ont pas des petits
bouts des archives télévisuelles mais
l'intégration complète ou aussi complète
que possible c'est pas les enfants de la
télé ça voilà c'est pas les enfants de
la télé c'est pas le zapping et c'est
pas et c'est pas vie de fou gags dont
vous vous en avez découvert vous même
des archives
oui évidemment desquels on passe non
vous connaissez bien la chaleur de la
télévision oui mais il ya des choses
vous êtes intéressés il ya quelques
tant le plus vieux documents qu'on n'est
jamais passé dans rembobine à qui est un
un document de 1950 1951 sur les sur les
télés club et qui monterait à la façon
dont dans des villages de l'aisne et de
l'oise
on se louer on achetait des postes de
télévision pour se regrouper comme dans
les pièces de cinéma pour aller voir les
les télévisions et c'est un document
assez extraordinaire sur les tous
premiers pas de la télévision bon voilà
on a en diffusion très bientôt un match
qui pour tous les amateurs de foot est
resté mythique qui est un quart de
finale retour de la de la coupe des
champions c'est saint-etienne kiev où
saint-etienne a remonté les trois buts
qui des cars qui lui permettait de se
qualifier c'est la fameuse épopée de 76
2 l'équipe 2 des verts mythique et on a
les équipes de l'inra ont réussi à
remettre à refabriquer un programme avec
les commentaires de thierry roland qui
était inaudible depuis depuis 40 ans
donc ça on va les téléspecteurs pour
revoir pour la première fois ce qu'ils
on avait vu il ya 40 ans en vous êtes
passionné il ya un plaisir à revoir ses
émissions là qu'est ce que ça dit aussi
des la télévision actuelle
alors on ne va pas dire que c'était tout
était mieux avant
parce que il ya des programmes qu'on
revoie et qui nous tombent des yeux
c'est à dire que je dis souvent on n'a
pas de limite dans nos choix c'est vrai
qu'on propose de la politique des
variétés des documentaires des chiens
vous iriez qu'aujourd'hui fait aussi
audacieux et créatif callen ya sans
doute moins d'audace mais dans les
programmes de la télévision des années
60-70 il n'y avait pas de l'audace
partout donc il ya aussi des choses que
l'on n'aurait pas forcément corsetée il
y avait des très grands créateurs des
très grands réalisateurs et des gens qui
faisaient alors il faut dire aussi que
souvent les la plus grande créativité
passer à des heures ou sur des chaînes
qui était moins regarder enfin il y
avait du temps de début de la deuxième
chaîne en deuxième partie sur la
deuxième chaîne c'est beaucoup moins
regardée que la première il y avait des
c'est là que passe et dim dam dom par
exemple on a fait un numéro de
rembobinage / dim dam dom avec des drm
tous les grands réalisateurs de cinéma
des années 70 sont passés par là c'est
vraiment une pépinière c'était une mine
des trésors mais c'était quand même dans
une case un petit peu confidentiel
laissant imaginer vous présenter cette
émission dans 20 ans vous montrez 3 nous
montrer quoi des pépites de l'audace
d'aujourd'hui
d'entrée dans l'anonymat mon passe-temps
fin non dans 20 ans je continue de
montrer le meilleur de la télévision
on a du stock l'émission vous aimez bien
qui mériterait de rester dans l'histoire
patrimoine de l'émission d'aujourd'hui
oui aujourd'hui c'est compliqué
je pense que comme quelques grandes
fictions qui mériterait d'être montré
qu'ils témoignent l'époque aussi des
séries des grandes séries télé une
émission de l'époque et une émission sur
les émissions de flux
c'est un peu compliqué parce que c'est
très lié à l'actualité
il faudrait la découper en petits
morceaux enfin diffuser vingt ans après
une émission d'actualité en entier c'est
alors je le disais c'est une transition
pour dire que vous travaillez à france
télévisions vous savez qu'ici à
l'assemblée les députés planchent sur la
réforme de l'audiovisuel
vous attendez qu'ils match est relancé
plusieurs concerts à france télé la
holding la future holding avec la avec
la radio avec radio france
vous êtes aussi un homme de radio c'est
une bonne chose ça alors il dans cette
loi il ya beaucoup de dispositions très
très très technique qui adapte le
système au numérique aux plateformes sur
les droits télé etc
moi ce que j'en ai vu c'est que pour la
gouvernance de l'ensemble ça crée un
métier impossible
un possible président de la holding ou
présidente de la holding parce qu'à une
holding qui va coiffer les différentes
sociétés de l'audiovisuel et qui aura si
j'ai bien compris une fonction de
coordination entre les différentes
instances entre la télévision radio une
fonction exécutive mais pas une fonction
éditoriale donc on aura quelqu'un qui
sera tout au sommet de l'édifice et qui
aura le poste le plus prestigieux mais à
qui on ne pourra pas demander des
comptes sur les programmes qui passent
sur telle chaîne ou sur tel radio bon
voilà j'entends une inquiétude yahia il
ya aussi des économies qu'on demande
notamment aux boîtes de production sont
fait déjà les économies sont faites et
les choralies nation éditorial elles
sont faites aussi en ce moment entre
france télé et radio france avec les
programmes communs qui se développe
notamment en local en région sur france
bleu et la belle impression travailler
avec moins de moyens quelques années
beaucoup moins moi je suis plus radio
france par des télévisions là à la
télévision moi je suis pas dans l'est
dans les comptes d
des sociétés de production ou dans le
dans les budgets mais oui on demande de
faire attention et je sais que je sais
que chaque année il ya des efforts qui
sont demandés aux différents programmes
concrets sur le salaire y compris sur y
compris pour eux c'est à vous l'émission
à laquelle je participe pour france 5 où
je peux pas m'empêcher de vous faire
réagir c'est le vin fort on se souvient
des mots d' emmanuel macron qui n'était
pas voilà 13 mm avec l'audiovisuel
public et qui avait eu des phrases
rapporté certains sur sur les programmes
qu'est ce qu'il lui plaît pas au
président public je ne n'ai aucune idée
je veux dire je les propos comme vous le
dites ont été rapportés c'était des
propos 8 cloud non il a des critiques il
avait qui il avait il avait d'ailleurs
je pense sincèrement que les politiques
du maire un général et président de la
république en fait partie août une
vision un peu budgétaire de france
télévisions et donc voilà ça coûte c'est
ça coûte toujours un peu cher il ya
toujours des économies à faire il ya
toujours voilà bon ensuite quand on
rentre dans le détail ce qui a été fait
depuis on voit que c'est plus compliqué
que ça à queue en effet sortir ensuite
une structure optimale c'est un exercice
auquel le même politique celui qui
critique se heurte aussi quand il s'agit
de deux d'entrer dans le dans
l'opérationnel il faut relativiser tout
ça c'était probablement un troupeau sur
le moment et pour terminer sur sur votre
actualité
patrick tonnes on le disait rembobinez
c'est une émission un peu nostalgique
est ce que est ce que vous même vous
êtes nostalgique delà de la radio du 7-9
de france inter de ces humoristes de son
atmosphère non non il faut pas dire son
nom il faut pas avoir de nostalgie pour
ça pour sa carrière d'autant que
ça a été mon choix de d'arrêter de
partir d'essayer autre chose donc en
temps réel vos mangas france inter un
peu manqué m'enfin je le mets je vous
pas avoir de regrets c'est un métier où
on avance et puis on attend de nouvelles
choses les humoristes mais il me manque
pas puisque je les écoute régulièrement
où j'allais en podcast on va parler
maintenant patrick cohen de ce livre les
plumes du pouvoir chez plon dont vous
êtes l'auteur michaël moreau les plumes
du pouvoir vous lever le voile en
quelque sorte sur les grands discours
politique pas seulement présidentielle
d'ailleurs on va le voir ceux des
présidents ceux de certains premier
ministre c'est ahmed tazir qu'il a lu
pour nous et qui nous a gardé quelques
grands discours quelques grands extraits
et quelques anecdotes regardez nous
restons disponibles pour toutes les
chances de la paix et des discours qui
font parfois l'histoire et des plumes
qui les écrivent les plumes du pouvoir
de michaël moreau pénètre à l'intérieur
du processus de fabrication
l'auteur interrogé plus d'une centaine
de personnalités présidents de la
république premiers ministres ministres
présidents d'assemblée collaborateurs et
plumes discrète 340 pages de confidences
beaucoup d'anecdotes aussi 1993 l'ancien
premier ministre pierre bérégovoy se
suicide après la déroute des
législatives françois mitterrand lui
rend hommage dans un discours qui fera
date
toutes les explications du monde ne
justifieront pas qu'on ait pu livrer aux
chiens l'honneur d'un homme est
finalement sa vie et l'on apprend que ce
discours est né dans le train paris
nevers avant les obsèques
furieux contre les journalistes et les
papiers contre viry gauvois michel
lachat race lachaud président ce sont
des
non ce sont des chiens rétorque que
mitterrand la phrase est forte elle est
reprise dans l'oraison funèbre
il y a les flèches il y a les
déclarations d'amour aussi les adieux de
chirac aux français en 2007
pas une minute je n'ai cessé d'agir pour
servir cette france magnifique cette
france que j'aime autant que je vous
aime en fait jacques chirac bloc pudique
il ne veut pas dire je vous aime les
plumes insiste il y a eu en tout cent
six versions du discours et à la fin ils
laissent la phrase qui marquera les
français plus récemment emmanuel macron
les événements de ces dernières semaines
dans l'hexagone et autres maires au
profondément troublé la nation ils ont
mêlé des revendications légitimes et un
enchaînement de violences inadmissibles
la crise des filets jaunes à la fin de
l'année 2018 bouleverse tout même les
discours présidentiel si ni les phrases
longues et les envolées lyriques
il faut être con si efficace dans la
petite histoire des discours il ya aussi
le plagiat avec ses façades maritimes la
mouche
cela vient de rohr qui nous relie au
monde sur le monde anglo saxon c'est sur
l'immensité septentrionale à façade
atlantique face à d'attenté qui nargue
depuis des siècles d'aventuré grand la
même phrase mêmes mots marine le pen lit
son discours d'entre deux tours de la
présidentielle
elle ne sait pas que son équipe lui a
refilé un discours de françois fillon
prononcé quinze jours avant effets
désastreux pour la candidate
le responsable c'est lui l'ancien
eurodéputé paul marie coûteaux plume
multicartes
il assume il
montrer que les deux droites pouvait
tenir des discours semblable plume du
pouvoir un métier difficile
sylvain fort la plume du président
macron ne sera resté qu'un peu moins
d'un an et demi à l'elysée avant de
quitter le navire
voilà on va parler de votre livre calme
au rouge accueille bertrand dicale de
france info qui va nous faire chanter
comme tous les vendredis soir mickaël
vous nous plonger dans l'envers du décor
les recettes de fabrication d'un
discours pourquoi vous avez vous lu au
fond vous intéresser à la fois assis
plumes mais à la manière dont ceux qui
vont les orateurs devons voilà demandé
des indications fait qu'il ya des trams
est ce que c'est ça dit des choses de
ceux qui prononcent des discours oui au
début j'ai moi j'avais ce qui
m'intéressait c'est moi j'ai travaillé
par le passé sur d'autres lives sur la
communication
finalement on n'est pas si loin de ça
aussi de quels sont les mots qu'on
choisit comme on les prononce comment on
fait des discours comment comment on dit
un certain nombre un certain nombre de
choses
après du coup je me suis plongée sur un
peu bas toute la période de la vème
république écrire des discours de de
gaulle à maquereau et on s'aperçoit ce
qu'on peut dire c'est un petit état des
lieux si on en reste au président alors
les présidents qui écrivent eux-mêmes
les clés résidents les plus tyranniques
ce qui faut réécrire jusqu'au dernier
moment
ceux qui vont à noter eux mêmes un
discours écrit par un autre vous pouvez
nous dresser un tableau n'ont finalement
on s'aperçoit qu'il ya des méthodes très
différentes par président
déjà il ya une évolution très
est très simple c'est que par exemple
aujourd'hui les discours c'est ça n'a
plus rien à voir avec ceux évidemment de
l'époque de de gaulle de gaulle il ya
très peu de discours il y en a
officiellement 67 par an toutes les
infos toutes les interventions ce qui
est très peu les discours sont plus
courts sont plus généraux là où
aujourd'hui les présidents prononce
énormément énormément de discours avec
énormément d annonces des discours sur
des sujets qui concernent plus
finalement qui autrefois étaient
prononcées par des ministres il ya une
autre vin il ya vraiment une inflation
du nombre de discours qui veut dire
aussi la façon dont on la
présidentialisation ça veut dire
beaucoup de chaussures sur comment
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs au début
emmanuel macron avait un peu voulu
revenir à une parole plus rare qu'on
disait verticale golo mitterrandienne
avant de se faire rattraper par
peut-être trop plein de parole puis de
vouloir revenir en arrière
vous expliquez bien celle du coup il ya
effectivement il ya des méthodes
différentes par président il ya un
président sur lequel ça m'a beaucoup
amusé de recueillir des idées à des
réactions des témoignages de l'époque
c'est jacques chirac parce que jacques
chirac il faisait relire ses discours
mais vraiment au mot près tout était
préparé il n'y avait jamais
d'improvisation c'était des séances de
relecture au salon vert de l'elysée le
le bureau qui est vraiment jouxte le
bureau du président à l'elysée avec
souvent le dimanche après midi parce
qu'ils s'ennuyaient le dimanche après
midi donc il convoquer tous ses
conseillers autour de la table ça durait
des heures les conseillers n'en pouvais
plus surtout la personne qui avait écrit
le discours par exemple christine
albanel qui n'en pouvaient plus de que
chacun pinaille sur une virgule
notamment par exemple dominique de
villepin qu'il pouvait avoir des grandes
envolées des petites précisions sur des
petits sur ce final en délire vous savez
d'ailleurs accès à des archives
incroyable de discours a noté damman
même de certains possédant les inonder
de france ami françois mitterrand
de françois hollande pour voir un petit
peu quelles sont leurs corrections ce
qui est intéressant aussi sur exemple
sur françois hollande c'est encore une
autre méthode puisque lui le tout tout
les toutes les plumes racontent qu'elles
ont vécu mais vraiment un enfer avec
avec lui puisqu'il faisait refaire sans
arrêt je pense qu'en fait finalement fin
ouais je pense que je pense finalement
il m'aimait pas en fait ce être
dépossédé de ça mais en même temps on
n'a besoin de personne pour pour se
faire aider
et finalement c'est là où ils étaient
ils pouvaient être le plus sec sur ses
discours des plumes raconte qu'elle
avait parfois des justes le discours
revenus avec des annotations avec marqué
par exemple c'est affligeant qui a fait
ce discours c'est un enfer ou pas ce
boulot là parce que quand vous étiez à
l'elysée et qu'on téléphoner au service
de presse était pas rare qu'on vous dit
c'est sacerdoce le discours qu écrit
sylvain fort et déjà réécrit - des
dizaines de fois c'est le calvaire
c'est le cas les verts n'ont enfin moi
je dirais pas ça je dirais d'abord c'est
un poste et je pense que le livre de
michaël moreau le montre extrêmement
bien je pense est le premier livre qui
le montre aussi bien c'est un poste
extrêmement complexe c'est à dire que on
se dit la personne qui écrit les
discours du président c'est un
conseiller les dans son bureau il gratte
il envoie au président il récupère il
envoie président il récupère c'est pas
du tout comme ça que ça se passe
c'est une vraie fabrique de la parole
cette fabrique de la parole elle est
profondément connectés évidemment au
président de façon intime elle est
connectée à tout le reste du cabinet de
façon également intime et donc en fait
c'est un calvaire non c'est à dire que
c'est très difficile
voilà c'est très difficile ça prend
beaucoup de temps beaucoup d'énergie
quel que soit le président je crois
parce que c'est évidemment chaque prise
de parole du président est essentielle
en réalité moi je trouve que tout dépend
à la base du rapport que le président de
la république entretient avec son
langage à lui juste leur donner moi de
vous interrompre et dans les livres de
michaël moreau et vous réagirez il ya
cette petite phrase de françois hollande
qui explique qu'au fond il trouve qu'il
est bien meilleur à l'oral qu'à l'écrit
qui a pas forcément un sens de la
formule et il parle de certains discours
qu emmanuel macron lui faisait part
ira divisés lorsqu'il était secrétaire
général de l'elysée est il un homme de
doha dite est plus que décrit le
président de la république
d'abord il n'a aucun président de la
république n'a le temps d'écrire ses
discours ça c'est de la donnée de base
ensuite tous les présidents de la
république prononce le discours qu'ils
ont envie de prononcer ses dires car
aucun président de la république qui
prend la copie qui dit tiens qu'est ce
qu'on raconte et qui va donc cesser un
rapport quand même d'auteur cas le
président de la république avec son
discours c'est pas c'est pas un truc où
il passe une commande et puis prend la
commande donc de toute façon il ya une
intervention très forte
ensuite je pense que le vrai sujet c'est
qu'est ce qui se passe entre la commande
et le moment où il prononce le discours
ça chaque président l'a dit à sa méthode
en ce qui concerne des manuels macro et
là moi je suis pas du tout d'accord avec
ce que dit françois hollande grippe d'un
ancien président est habilité moi je
peux vous le dire parce que j'ai
travaillé avec lui donc quand vous
produisez un discours que vous le
souhaitez à la relecture du président de
la république il ya une chose que vous
êtes vous êtes assez conscients que
c'est la première version n'est jamais
la bonne d'accord ça c'est certain
on sait très bien qu'un prêt à ça j'ai
mal mais surtout on a cette espèce de
petite mauvaise conscience aux é tir
dans tel passage et pas été très bon la
phrase est pas complètement decker on le
sait mais on ne m'en passe quand même le
truc c'est qu'est-ce que vous donner au
président c'est une trame c'est déjà un
discours très aboutie complètement est
toujours une expérience de travail avec
le président emmanuel macron c'est qu'à
chaque fois qu'il y avait un truc moi
même dans mon for intérieur je me disais
tiens c'est peut-être pas idéal
il leur père est à chaque fois qu'il y
avait une phrase qui était un peu bancal
à chaque fois qu'il y avait un
paragraphe un peu trop gras à chaque
fois qu'ils avaient une idée qui était
pas amené de manière optimale et je le
savais je le sentais je les ai bon voilà
il improvise aussi le il le saisit sa
quel est le discours dont vous êtes le
plus fier on parle beaucoup de l'hommage
au colonel beltrame
on parle aussi du discours des
bernardins sur les relations entre
l'église catholique et l'état ou encore
je pense qu'il ya quelques discours vous
savez on dit parfois on est très fiers
d'un discours et puis produit aucun
effet en fait on est fiers d'un discours
quand on se dit qu'il a été écouté c'est
à dire qu'il a passé la rampe et au fond
les discours que vous mentionnez c'est
pas forcément les meilleurs discours
j'en sais rien en fait je suis pas sûr
qu'un discours est ici alors il reste
mais c'est un discours qui reste un
discours qui réussit c'est le président
de la république s'exprime toujours dans
un contexte dans un
mme en particulier le discours réussi
c'est quand la parole du président
rencontre le moment je pense qu'en effet
dans les cas que vous citez il ya une
vague attentes dans le public dans
l'opinion dans la presse et les gens se
disent tiens qu'est ce qui va nous
raconter sur ce sujet et quand on sent
que pouf on est dans le mille quoi qu'on
a mis la petite bille milieu du
labyrinthe on se dit lassé un disco
réussi même si par ailleurs il ya
peut-être des discours tout aussi réussi
mais qui ont juste pour des mérites de
n'avoir pas retenu l'attention du
chaland
regardons la rencontre et je vous donne
ma parole juste après entre un discours
un homme et un moment nous sommes en
décembre 2010 cette place de la
madeleine devant l'église regarde et je
sais que vous vous attendez à ce qu'ils
surgissent de quelque part il serait sur
une moto ils avanceraient vers vous il
entamerait la première chanson et vous
commenceriez à chanter avec lui michael
marot c'est évidemment l'hommage à
johnny hallyday figure rhétorique la
prosopopée j'ai découvert ce terme par
laquelle on s'est parlé le défunt pour
le faire revivre d'une certaine façon ça
c'est du maquereau jamais séduit sylvain
fort du maquereau est un exercice
totalement inédit pour un président de
répliques ce même on se sait c'est la
première fois qu'il y avait un discours
finalement comme ça 2 sur la pelouse
lors d'un hommage national devant une
église le jour de la journée nationale
de la laïcité c'était le 9 décembre avec
un exercice d'ailleurs dont beaucoup
disent qu'ils ne pourraient plus se
faire peut-être aujourd'hui après la
crise et gilet jaune après macron finale
puis emmanuel macron finalement à
changer sa façon de faire des discours
des discours - moins solennel c'est
chercher un petit peu sur comment
prendre la parole des discours ayant
peut-être le sentiment que le discours
lui donner une image de lui un peu trop
un peu trop vertical donc ça c'est
vraiment le délit discours du des
premiers mois du quinquennat
et beaucoup disent qu'ils ne pourraient
plus leur faire aujourd'hui un exercice
très inédit dit fort qui le confirme
c'est que la cdu c'est du mâcon 100% et
que c'est toute la nuit vous avez rien
sisi sinon évidemment fait ça ensemble
et là tout le début c'est quasiment de
la dernière minute ça vient de lui en se
disant la situation est inédite au fond
à la base et doit parler dans l'église
mais évidemment c'est pas et commode en
plus c'est la journée de la laïcité
c'est le 9 décembre
et vous voyez il se retrouve sur le
parvis mais avec la famille à quelques
mètres est au fond un public juste un
peu plus loin dans un contexte de
proximité qui était pas non plus très
anticipé donc dès le début il faut
trouver des mots qui accroche qui capte
l'attention et du public le public au
début je vous rappelle siffler le
président c'est pour ça c'est aussi déjà
un public pas acquis et et le public et
je n'ose pas d'y retourner
enfin en tout cas rqap t et écoute ce
que dit président à ce moment là on
conclure patrick cohen qu'elles sont
vous pour vous les grandes plumes
présidentielle vous les connaissez qui
ont au service de quelques grands
discours présidentiel
alors donc j'ai envie de parler plutôt
des petits discours parce que oui parce
que parce que je suis très admiratif
devant le travail de ces plumes qui doit
fournir une une masse considérable de
dire ou pas ce qu'on retient les grands
discours vient tous les petits c'est
vrai alors ça j'en ai entendu des
centaines des discours dans ma vie de
reporter politique et ma love
je pars dont j'allais dire
malheureusement mais c'est vrai que le
président que j'ai le plus suivi c'est
jacques chirac et jacques chirac dans
son deuxième mandat il avait une façon
absolument mécanique de débiter des
discours dont il n'était pas l'auteur il
est bon et je me souviens notamment
je vous jure que je vais entendu avec
mes oreilles d'une remise de décoration
à jean françois humbert qui était un
ancien président de région franche-comté
sénateur du doubs et à deux ou trois
reprises dans son discours c'était à
l'elysée devant un petit salle de
jacques chirac il disait toutes les
lettres qui était imprimé en gros
caractères sur sa feuille et sera dit
jean françois humbert né à besançon dans
le doubs pss
département du doubs ce qui a vu naître
et et là on a on a le le paroxysme du du
discours plaqué président qu'il lit tout
les toutes les lettres et toutes les
phrases de sa plume est donc ce qui
change beaucoup
évidemment c'est le rapport à
l'improvisation aussi c'est l'oralité du
discours parce que chaque président
voilà on a eu des derniers présidents
aussi bien françois hollande
emmanuel macron aujourd'hui et nicolas
sarkozy qui était qu'ils étaient
capables de sortir de leur texte
merci on aurait pu continuer encore
longtemps c'est passionnant de vous
écouter parce qu'il faut maintenant
laisser la place à bertrand dicale ce
rappel le titre de votre livre michaël
moreau c'est absolument savoureux
ruez-vous sur les plumes du pouvoir chez
plon bertrand on termine en chansons
alors nous parler de ce soir d'une femme
derrière
oui parce que vous avez vu cette soirée
des césars cahute en conséquence
polémique
on a peut-être un peu oublié ce qu'il a
dit dans son discours d'ouverture la
présidente de la soirée sandrine
kiberlain
elle disait qu'on a tous une vieille
habitude qui nous a été enseigné à
l'école en famille par les vieux livres
qui est que derrière chaque grand homme
il ya une femme derrière derrière et
derrière les hommes on en a depuis
quelques jours la démonstration avec le
procès des époux fillon
pénélope fillon est tellement derrière
son mari que la justice ou des savoir
pourquoi pendant des dizaines d'années
elle a touché un salaire sans que soit
évidente la réalité de son travail
alors ce procès évidemment un procès de
pratique politique et morale douteuse
aussi le
le procès d'un autre temps et c'est vrai
que si on cherche dans la chanson des
dernières années la parole de pénélope
fillon de ces femmes qui sont derrière
cette parole on n'arrive pas à les
trouver ailleurs que dans des 78 tours
qui font de creech petric là dans la
chanson contemporaine
quand on essaie de savoir ce qui se
passe dans le partage des rôles dans un
couple c'est plutôt sain qui voudrait
faire de moi une épouse modèle en accord
parfait avec
[Musique]
posez la volonté mais pauline croze et
oui c'est pauline croze la femme
fossiles de pauline croze c'est une
chanson de votre adolescence je suppose
c'est une chanson de 2005 c'était bon
mais il y a des voix quand même qu'ils
rendent hommage à ses épouses discrète
et docile écoutez gérard de l'est les
femmes femmes femmes aujourd'hui
qu'ils font sans arrêt
[Musique]
alors ça se passe en bretagne
c'est un mariage de l'ancien temps cette
jolie expression un seul voyage dans
leur vie le mariage avec l'homme devant
la femme derrière c'est ça le mariage
dans lequel c'est françois qui s'occupe
de tout bah c'est un peu cette chanson
mais gérard delahaye ne parlait
évidemment pas de l'épousé d'un élu de
la république et côté quai neves dans la
montagne 20 ans gp
[Musique]
oh
il me
la terre
avec la mois
alors ça ne se passe pas dans un château
de notre de l'ouest de la france ça se
passe dans une petite ferme au nord de
la bretagne si l'uci la paysanne si on
veut chercher comme ça les pousse docile
le grillon du foyer qui n'a pas d'accroc
sa robe de mariée comme disait brassens
dans une chanson qui s'appelle pénélope
d'ailleurs ça me rappelle que l'enjeu
aujourd'hui l'enjeu pour les femmes ce
n'est pas seulement sortir de l'ombre de
derrière c'est fait pour la plupart
d'entre eux c'est de justement obtenir
l'égalité devant pas de réussir à
démontrer qu'on est bien derrière son
mari mais plutôt le combat de l'égalité
de la parité
on y revient d'ailleurs dimanche 8 mars
journée internationale des droits de la
femme
les fermes assortis l'effet mousty un
groupe toulousain toulousain et
brésiliens nous rappelle les faits
mousty nous rappelle les les femmes de
toulouse fait moustiques nous rappelle
quel est l'enjeu de cette journée du 8
mars
on va
merci patron merci l'effet booster je ne
connaissais pas on est très en retard
merci à tous d'être venus sur le plateau
dès le cp merci patrick cohen bonne
semaine c'est le week-end profitez bien
à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]